uh mike pillow the ceo and founder of my
pillow mike lindell
he was also at the trump rally this is
the last element of the trump rally
we're going to look at today
he arrived in ohio for the rally he was
completely out of breath
and he again seems to be talking about
lawsuits against machines remember he
wants to sue every machine we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines yeah i actually
um i have a computer monitor that has
gone into witness protection because it
is very much afraid of this pillow
lawsuit listen to this guy
yesterday was a historical day in
history the history of america well yeah
i mean every day is historical that's
true uh we filed the first
preliminary injunction in the state of
arizona to get rid of the machines once
and for all
and that's the first of many many i want
to do all 50 carrie lake and uh
mark fincham we're the plaintiffs
and uh the defendant is katie hobbs the
secretary of state and their maricopa
county and pima county county
commissioners and staff and our
commissioners i think there
and uh this is so important because it's
it really sounds like any day now
they're gonna put trump uh back in
office this guy has a following
trump praises him at every single one of
his rallies here he is
uh talking about the masks on planes
coming off have really reinvigorated a
lot of people um all the other judges
how would you like to been a judge back
then have been the first one to step
forward and have your family attacked or
whatever yeah they lived in fear but now
since we all know the evidence is there
and everything the judges are going to
be brave remember that donald trump
appointed over i think there's almost
500 judges look at what one just did
down in florida was that amazing they
ordered the mask on on the airplanes
it's beautiful you know
one judge to say god should change the
course
and this is what's going to happen with
these preliminary injunctions the judges
are going to start pouring it on saying
we can't have these corrupt machines
you know when a country when you're in a
country
and machines that must be it by why
can't he
he out of breath voliminary a junction
uh it's it's all bizarre here he claims
trump really won ohio by 3.4 million
which would be an extra half million
votes for trump where did those come
from we don't know in the in this great
state of ohio
the big lie which is the big lie they
say donald trump won by 475
000 votes
it with your machines and with
everything went on you guys had
supposedly pretty good voting rolls well
that's not true dr frank went over all
your stuff but by the way for people
listening the reason pillow's screaming
is there's like a crowd that has kind of
gathered to listen to him in the state
of ohio donald trump really won three
million four hundred thousand to two
million four hundred and thirty thousand
that's another five hundred thousand
votes that were stolen so that's
completely made up and then lastly here
is pillow actually addressing the rally
crowd and here he says we've gotta get
back to god we're living in the greatest
time in history because everything's
getting revealed when we get through
this it's going to be the most beautiful
place we're going to have fair elections
we're going to put god back in our
schools and we will once again be one
nation under god we're living and of
course putting god back into schools
would go completely against the
constitution of the united states in
separation of church and states so this
man is a hero
in a normal timeline and a normal
universe
nobody would ever have voted for trump
and people like pillow would never be
revered as heroes but alas we are not in
normal times and these are the heroes
that the right-wing cult has
i hope that you viewers listeners to our
show take your privacy seriously things
i talk about all the time internet
service providers record what you do
online they sell the data it's there for
eternity
big tech companies search engine social
media they're tracking almost everything
you do
they hang on to that information forever
too i don't let all of these
corporations spy on me i hope you don't
either because avoiding all of it is
simple and affordable today i use atlas
vpn to make myself invisible online one
subscription covers all my devices you
don't have to be a tech person you just
install it once you press a button you
forget about it you enjoy your privacy
if you don't use a vpn a record of your
internet activity will always exist and
change hands tech companies make money
off of you respect your own privacy
enough to install a vpn it's so easy
click the link below to get atlas vpn
for 82 percent off less than two bucks a
month and you'll get one month for free